trust is critical in any relationship
one way to operationalize trust is to be
vulnerable today we will discuss
vulnerability and leading with
it my name is Matt Abrahams I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the
podcast today I look forward to speaking
with Jacob Morgan Jacob is a speaker
futurist and author of several books
including his most recent one called
leading with vulnerability how to unlock
your greatest superpower to transform
yourself your team and your organization
additionally Jacob hosts the great
leadership podcast Jacob thanks for
being here with me thank you for having
me I'm looking forward to it I am
looking forward to this as well so let's
get started you've spent a lot of your
time exploring leadership and what
Future Leaders need to do to be more
successful given our focus on
communication on this podcast what can
you tell us about the role communication
plays in effective leadership and what
communication advice do you have for
leaders at any level of an
organization well I think it's safe to
say that without communication there is
no leadership right I mean if you if you
can't communicate effectively how can
you lead other people so I think it's
very Central to how we lead now of
course it's also important to note that
communication has also changed quite a
bit it's funny it's one of those things
that's been around forever but also one
of those things that has changed more
over the past 10 15 years than anything
else because of the different platforms
that we have at our disposal the tools
the
resources now I think the second part of
your question was communication advice
that that I would have for people that
are out there probably a few things this
actually ties into some of the themes
from my book I think the best way that
you can communicate is to bridge
together two pieces of compet and
connection I think especially for if
you're a leader anytime that you want to
communicate with people you want to be
able to demonstrate that you can connect
with them but you also want to
demonstrate that you have that level of
competence so it goes into this theme of
leading with vulnerability if you can
bring those two pieces of the equation
together I think you're going to be a
very very effective
Communicator I love that idea of
competence and connection in the class I
teach we talk a lot about warmth and
competence and how you have to balance
those out it's about immediacy and
you're right that things have changed
dramatically in the last several years
and are changing as we speak the way we
communicate the tools we have to
communicate and as Leaders we need to
adjust and adapt for sure I want to dig
deeper into vulnerability because your
your new book distinguishes between
being vulnerable and leading with
vulnerability can you help us understand
what you mean by that distinction and
and can you please share some attributes
of vulnerable leaders sure so when most
people think of vulnerability they think
of the this concept of sharing a
personal challenge or a struggle
admitting to a mistake so what I've come
to realize is that vulnerability for
leaders is not the same as it is for
everybody else you have to bring
together these two pieces of the
equation competence and connection so
let's say for example I work for you
Matt and um you know I'm showing up to
work and I made a mistake I really
screwed something up and it's I have to
come clean on that mistake that's a very
vulnerable thing to do so I could come
to you and I could approach it in one of
two ways the vulnerable way is to say
hey Matt you know what man I'm really
sorry I screwed this up like I made a
mistake or I could come to you and I
could say hey Matt you know what I'm
really sorry I screwed this up I made a
mistake here's what I learned from the
mistake that I made and here are some
steps that I'm going to put into place
to make sure that this mistake doesn't
happen again the first way that I
communicated with you is vulnerable the
second way that I communicated to you is
leading with vulnerability so all of
this comes down to this what I call the
vulnerable leader equation leadership
plus vulnerability not just the
vulnerability piece really insightful
there I would be honored to have you as
an employee you you are so talented at
all the things you do you would fire me
in 30
seconds well I don't know but what I'm
hearing there is that being open and
vulnerable is not the answer it's being
vulnerable with some Vision some
explanation some direction that follows
or complements it that is what really
makes the difference so let me ask a
follow-up question for many of us it's
hard enough just to be vulnerable right
it's hard to admit our mistakes or that
we don't know what advice and guidance
do you have for us as individuals to
help us just get the first part of that
equation down being vulnerable and then
what do we we need to do as Leaders to
build nourish and support a culture of
vulnerability so everybody feels
comfortable leading with vulnerability
so the first part of that question is
interesting because the second part of
the equation is the answer to the first
part of the equation so we surveyed
14,000 employees and we asked them
what's the number one thing that's
keeping you from being vulnerable at
work and the number one response by far
that everybody gave us was I don't want
to be perceived as being weak or
incompetent
so it kind of makes you wonder you take
a step back well why does being
vulnerable make you seem weak or
incompetent well because if you just
talk about the mistake if you just talk
about the failure and the struggles and
the challenges that's literally what
you're doing you are making yourself
seem weak or incompetent because that's
the only part of the equation that
you're looking at so how do you make
yourself more comfortable with that well
you talk about what you're doing to
close that Gap what you're doing to to
get better what you're doing to move
things forward so it seems to me that
part of what you're saying is the way
that we can feel more comfortable being
vulnerable is to reframe what it means
to be vulnerable conveying how I'm
taking advantage of opportunities to
improve and that's a very different
reframe one that for me personally is
more motivational and one that I can see
would be received much better by others
one more Point really quick on that so
it's not just a reframe it's a
demonstration because it's one thing to
do a mental reframe it's another thing
to demonstrate that so for example you
might see that you asking for help about
something or admitting to a mistake is
an opportunity is an opportunity to get
better right in your mind that's how you
perceive it the other person doesn't
know that that's how you're thinking
about it the other person is just going
to think well Matt keeps asking me for
help so reframing is a part of it but
demonstrating that you are actually
getting better that you are trying to
improve is critical not just for you but
also for those around you so that you
can demonstrate that leadership piece I
really appreciate that addition you are
absolutely right uh reframing happens
first and then you have to demonstrate
so what is it that leaders can do to
build nourish and support a culture of
vulnerability where people feel
comfortable
demonstrating you lead by example if you
want other people that you work with to
act and behave a certain way it has to
start with you right so if you lead with
vulnerability then those around you will
lead with vulnerability now in the book
I talk about these eight attributes
vulnerable leaders typically use and we
don't need to go through all eight of
them but this concept of leading by
example I think is the most critical one
of demonstrating the behaviors that you
want other people to demonstrate and one
of the visuals that I have in the book
is this idea of leveling the playing
field and what leveling the playing
field means is that there is an a Very
explicit meaning obvious everybody knows
of a relationship between the employee
and the leader and everybody knows that
the employee depends on the leader
everybody knows that the employee is
vulnerable to the leader just inherent
in the position that they're in meaning
that if I'm your boss I can make your
life hell I can put you on terrible
projects you are vulnerable to me just
by the fact that you work for
me however there's another relationship
that exists leaders are very vulnerable
to their people because you have to
imagine if you work for me and you don't
do a good job who does that reflect
poorly on it reflects poorly on the team
and it reflects poorly on me so I as a
leader I'm also vulnerable to you the
difference is is in that first scenario
the relationship is explicit and in the
second scenario the relationship is
implicit in other words we never talk
about that second relationship leaders
don't tell their employees hey I can't
do this without you I'm vulnerable to
you I'm dependent on you we don't talk
about that and so one of the people
people that I interviewed is Sim Sitkin
he's one of the world's leading experts
on trust and he did some research and he
found that when you look at the
literature there are 22 different
definitions of trust and all of these
definitions come back to being
vulnerable the more senior we we become
we assume that we don't need to be
vulnerable to our people because we're
in a leadership role we're in an
authority role but we assume that
everybody needs to be vulnerable to us
and that everybody needs to trust us so
by Leading with vulnerability you level
that playing field and when you level
the playing field you open the door for
collaboration for trust for engagement
for productivity so the best piece of
advice for leaders is level the playing
field lead by example you do it first
and other people will follow
suit I love how direct that advice is
and how clear it is as you say it of
course makes sense but I see it time and
time again not playing out where leaders
feel that their job is to have all the
answers to do it right to be a beacon of
perfection and emulating that and it
builds in difficulty having them lead by
example I think is a great bit of advice
Among the other bits of advice that you
have in the book speaking of the book
you you talk about climbing the
vulnerability Mountain what is this
framework and and how can we leverage it
do I have to put my my boots on and get
my water bottle ready metaphoric I
suppose yes you do leading with
vulnerability is akin to climbing this
mountain you're probably going to make
mistakes you might fall and get beat up
you might have to backtrack because you
went up the wrong path and you're going
to have to go around another path so
when I say climbing the vulnerability
Mountain what I mean is try to identify
something that you can do today or
tomorrow something easy it might be
something like asking for help with
something small and then just letting
the other person know what you're going
to do to help solve that problem for
yourself going forward and then identify
what's at that peak of the mountain for
you talking about a personal challenge
or struggle and and how that's being
applicable for your leadership Journey
or how it's impacting you at work right
that's at the peak of the mountain for
me and so you define the base you define
the peak and then on a regular basis you
take steps to climb that Peak and go up
that mountain that's ultimately what
we're looking at and what we're doing so
it seems to me that at the heart of the
advice you're giving is we have to
reflect we have to take time to reflect
on ourselves to help us prioritize and
understand where we're at and what's
important to us and then I also heard
you say we have to think about the
stories that we tell ourselves and the
stories that we tell others to really
help cement Our intention for what it is
we're striving to achieve and the notion
of reflection is one we've talked about
often and the notion of Storytelling
we've also talked about often on the
podcast but putting these two together
in a way to help us think about our
vulnerability how we build trust how we
connect with others is quite unique and
I thank you for for bringing those two
points that we've discussed before
together now Jacob I'd like to switch
gears a bit almost 10 years ago you
wrote a book about the future of work
and in the 10 years since that book came
out we have seen major shifts in the way
we work globalization the pandemic AI
you name it all of these have
dramatically altered work as know it and
the work that leaders have to do within
those new and changing contexts when you
look at where we were 10 years ago and
where we are now I'm curious what do you
see happening in the next 10 years that
will impact leadership and the way we
work and and what can we do to prepare
for it so the next 10 years it's hard to
not say that technology is going to play
a pivotal role in how we work
specifically something like a chat GPT I
don't know about you and your team I use
it on a regular basis it has become an
integral part of how I work and how my
team works so Jacob you host the great
leadership podcast and I was very
fortunate to be one of your guests and
like me you've been able to interview
some just amazing people uh what two
insights stand out the most to you from
guests you've spoken with there are a
few I think interesting insights that
come up the first is that I've had the
opportunity to interview a lot of a lot
of CEOs and a lot of Business Leaders on
the podcast and one of the things I'm
constantly Amazed by is
that these are CEOs of multi-billion
dollar companies who are responsible for
the lives of tens or hundreds of
thousands of employees and it's funny
because when you talk to them they're
just normal people They share stories
about their kids they talk about
mistakes that they're making like little
dumb things they talk about I mean
they're just like normal people and it's
the the perception that we have of them
the the goggles the glasses that we view
them with paints them in this such a
very different way I had for example the
former CEO of sisan who was just talking
about how he was dyslexic and that he
struggles with so many different types
of things and that he never shared this
with anybody until somebody on his team
one day shared that he was dyslexic and
he accidentally said oh yeah me too I
think a lot of leaders out there are
genuinely good people but they struggle
with the same things that we all
struggle with whether it's impostor
syndrome whether it's being taught
something in a in a way that no longer
makes sense whether it's finding time I
interviewed the CEO of Blue Shield in
California Paul Markovich and this was
during the pandemic when he was working
ridiculous hours and he was telling me a
story about how he was on the phone with
one of his employees one of his
employees were challenging him about
something and he just burst into tears
and started crying just started weeping
out of nowhere so that to me has been
very interesting just to to get to know
a lot of the leaders and the people that
I bring on just as human beings and not
just as these like magical unicorns the
second interesting piece of insight for
me has been that everybody has a very
unique or different way that they get
things done uh in fact one of the
questions that I always like to ask
these CEOs is do you have a leadership
hack and everyone has like little
different things little spins on life
little perspectives that they bring to
the table that maybe other people don't
for leadership I think there is a
general structure of what's expected but
there's also lot of like playroom that
you as a leader can bring your own
personality your own Vibe your own kind
of spin of things and I I always find
that to be very very fascinating I think
that realizing that the leaders we
admire we follow are regular people is
is a reminder we all need to have we
have this image of these folks being
different and unique in some way and and
they are they certainly have their own
skills but the fact that they're regular
people I think is really humanized in
and appropriate for us to know thinking
about how people leverage certain
behaviors to help them be more efficient
I always find that fascinating I'm
always looking for efficiency tips for
sure so Jacob before we end uh I'd like
to ask you a few questions one is
tailored specifically to you and then
two are ones that I ask almost everybody
all right let's do it so we've talked a
lot about vulnerability and I'm curious
if you are comfortable sharing with us
something that makes you feel vulnerable
I'll start by saying I feel very exposed
and vulnerable when I write I am much
more comfortable speaking than writing
what what's a situation or something
that makes you feel particularly
vulnerable and exposed oh so many and
for me it's not often times negative
things but it's you know good things for
example if I am giving a genuine
compliment to someone or let's say I'm
giving a toast to a friend or to a
family member and I'm trying to show
genuine emotion and be authentic like
there's a difference between saying like
hey you know like Hey Dad happy birthday
hope you have a great year I love you
health happiness blah blah blah it's
very different to give a toast and say
hey Dad you know I just want to say you
know you mean so much to me you guys
came from the Republic of Georgia you
allowed me to to grow up in like it's
it's a very different right a very
different way to talk so for me whenever
I have to share that kind of genuine
emotion that positive emotion is to me a
very very vulnerable thing and again
it's not a bad thing it's a good thing
but it still is uh you feel a lot of
that emotional exposure thank you and
and thank you for sharing and being
vulnerable with me and with those
listening who is a communicator that you
admire and
why there's probably a few for different
reasons my dad is one which sounds kind
of funny because he's actually not a
great communicator he speaks with a
heavy Russian
accent he sometimes misuses words or
says the wrong word or sometimes will'll
even make up a word but what I think
makes him a good communicator is that he
he's really good at getting to the point
what I like about my dad is that there
is no BS there you know exactly what
you're getting you know exactly who
you're talking to there's no sugar
coating there's no beating around the
bush like it's straight to the point and
that
may or may not be a good thing but
that's something that I like and and he
tries but I want to throw one more in
there because it's the opposite of my
dad and that's my wife Blake and she's a
great communicator for a very different
reason in that she's very good at being
intuitive at having emotional
intelligence at understanding how I and
other people are feeling and being able
to deliver a message based on the
feedback that she's getting on an
emotional level and they are so so
opposite I cannot even tell you but they
both have I think their unique strengths
that they bring to the table must be
interesting watching the two of them
have conversations for sure but I
appreciate yeah I appreciate the
directness and yet the ability to be
intuitive pay attention to the Nuance of
what's happening our skills that we can
all benefit from final question what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe first
three ingredients I think number one is
intention what is the purpose of what it
is that you are saying or doing uh I
think a second key ingredient is Clarity
is making sure that you get the message
across in the right way making sure that
if it's a complex topic people can
understand it if it's a message to
motivate and Inspire that that's the
outcome that it has and I think number
three is knowing who you're delivering
the message to right if I'm talking to a
friend or if I'm talking to somebody
that I work with or if I'm talking to
the CEO of the company giving a talk the
way that I communicate is going to be
very different and so I think those are
the three at least for me crucial
ingredients for effective communication
especially if you're in a leadership
role very key elements I love this
notion of intention and then paying
attention to who it is you're
communicating to really insightful and
in fact Jacob everything today has been
very insightful thank you I appreciate
you being vulnerable and leading with
vulnerability and I appreciate you
demonstrating connection and competence
with me and with our audience best of
luck to you with your podcast as well as
your new book leading with vulnerability
thank you so much thanks so much for
having
me thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for for more information and
episodes visit gb. stanford.edu or
subscribe to our show wherever you get
your podcasts find us on social media at
Stanford
GSB